i'm like you i've had my wife literally
squirt in my mouth multiple times you
know what i'm saying let's do that buddy
you know what i'm saying
what are we doing if we ain't trying to
please the ones we love
what yes sir ain't nothing like having
your girl ride your face and then things
go you know but the thing is though the
reason i brought up the piss thing is
you might have a crazy night
and the sheets are [ __ ]
mattress gets wet you wake up the next
morning
it's a lot a little pissy of a smell you
gotta have a [ __ ] room
the [ __ ] room yeah
you got a [ __ ] room and you got a [ __ ]
room in the sleep room yeah
that's interesting so you you were just
designing play room in the lay room i
don't even like the word
i don't like the word six i just say it
so everybody know what i'm talking about
right but it's spiritual it's spiritual
unification i pray before i have sex
this is spiritual
you'll pray before sex yes every time
every time it's spiritual that's
interesting
yeah i mean i i i adore
you'll pray during sex yeah i'll just be
thanking god
would you ever stop and be like give me
a sec no no no no but just in your head
no i say it out loud
like if like if i'm just in it
and i'm just really punching that dick
i'm talking about punching that dick in
her stomach i'll just be like yes lord
yes lord cause this
i never thought like coming from where i
come from
me i know people look at me like kevin
case but i don't see kevin gates right i
see regular old kevin so i'm like
man it's a blessing to be hitting a big
booty [ __ ] you got a body of uh a a a a
a work of art in front of you i'm
talking about i got a workout oh and i'm
time out
i'm time i'm just having my way and it's
making them mad big buddy [ __ ] i'mma
hear from no bag it just it's just a
blessing to me cause i ain't you know
we didn't grow up just having this in my
living room you know right